[Music]
i'm just in a different place
i think a lot of us are in a different
place after the last couple years
kelly's whole world has changed in court
documents obtained by e.t she's now
considered legally single her high
profile divorce though remains ongoing
remember that prenup she took back her
maiden name and still has to pay ex
brandon blackstock nearly 200 grand a
month so when it came to the new song
she wrote for her christmas album we
couldn't help but think there might be a
hidden message
christmas isn't canceled just you is the
single from the record there were so
many things that were taken from us and
like in cancel also i think if you've
been in like a relationship that didn't
work out and it's like you're used to
these surroundings you're used to this
place that doesn't mean it's like all
ruins
[Music]
this record
has some songs on there that you're not
used to for christmas some are like
let's really feel all the feelings um
christmas song
kelly won't be spending christmas at
this encino california home she once
shared with brandon she just sold the
spectacular 10 000 square foot eight
bedroom estate the mansion with
farmhouse vibes went for 8.24 million as
for her new album the 39 year old rok4
classic looks to promote the holiday
project the singles out now the album
when christmas comes around drops
october 15th kelly collab with ariana
grande and chris stapleton it's a
different christmas album it kind of
feels more like an album like that you
release in or like normal but then
there's like christmas sprinkled on it
but anyway i love it
[Music]